Fortune is made in better not new I made
a bet with the founder of the biggest
company in our portfolio before we
decided to do a deal with him they
wanted to go in this new Direction with
a new product and so he's like hey this
thing's going to be awesome and they'd
already built all this stuff and they
were ready to release it and I really
felt that it was going to be a terrible
idea you survey your clients before you
launch it and you put your offer against
my offer if my offer wins we do the deal
if my offer doesn't win go on your
separate way my offer versus their offer
had one specific difference their offer
was this entirely new thing that they
were really into my offer was more help
on the thing they had already sold the
people guess what the result was 85
percent of the customers their entire
base said they just wanted more help
with the first product they had sold
them and so that teases out one of my
fundamental laws of businesses that the
best thing to sell people is more of
what they've already bought